SAM DUTTON: --Sam Dutton.
I'm a developer advocate based--
I am actually Australian,
but based in London.
I do a lot of work on
progressive web apps.
One thing, by the way, before I
get started, I work quite a lot
with audio and video APIs.
And I've worked with the WebRTC
team in the past as well.
So if you have
particular questions
about video on the web, WebRTC,
real time communication,
please feel free to
come and chat to me.
I'll be here for
the rest of the day.
I'd love to hear the kind
of things you're working on.
So we've heard a lot today
about the core principles
of progressive web app design.
They need to be fast.
And they need to be reliable.
The core idea here is
that we're building
things that work
really well no matter
what the state of the
network or the conditions,
the type of the device that
your users are working on.
We need to better
handle flaky networks.
And we need really great,
smooth interactions and seamless
navigation, no matter what the
conditions are, no matter what
the device is.
And what we're talking
about, in a way,
is developing trust, the trust
that the user has for your app.
We're talking about that kind of
engagement you get with an app.
You know when you use
a really good app,
you feel that real connection
right from the start?
So I'd like to talk a little
bit more about that part of it,
the way that you build that
engagement with your user
right from the moment when they
install and first use your app.
So I'd like to begin
that by looking
at the center of
the world for users
on mobile, which
is the home screen.
And the core idea here
is that your web apps
must have visibility on
the user's home screen.
And of course, we've
had this for a while.
We've had the Add
to Home Screen item
in the menu, which was great.
It was a way, essentially, of
bookmarking a link to your site
and adding an icon for that
on the user's home screen.
Now that's been
around for some time.
And it works pretty well.
But there were several
problems with this.
The first, most obvious problem
is that most users never
discovered this.
Most users never went to
the menu and found that.
And what we found is that
really only a very small number
of users actually
use the menu item.
It's buried.
People don't find it.
Secondly, it functions as a way
of adding a bookmark to a page.
So if the user is on a
page deep within your site,
and they select
Add to Home Screen,
well that adds a
link to that page.
Whereas you probably
want your users
to start with the index
page for the site.
The third problem that we've
had with the old fashioned Add
to Home Screen is
simply that when
users see an icon on
their home screen,
they expect that
app to work offline.
And when you add your icons
to the user's home screen,
you're making a
contract with the user
that when they click on that
icon, when they tap that icon,
that something will happen,
even when they're offline.
So the first way that
we've improved this
is through the web app manifest.
People in the room
here, could you
put up your hand if you use a
web app manifest on your site?
Does anyone use a
web app manifest?
That's pretty good.
That's good.
This is a really,
really simple way
to give the browser
information about your site.
If you do nothing else, this
can take you five minutes
to add this to
your site and give
the browser better
information about how
to work with your site.
So it's really straightforward.
You create a
manifest file, which
is simple JSON that
describes your app.
And then you add a link to
that manifest in the head
element of your document,
of the HTML file.
If we look at the
kind of details here,
you'll see, for example,
we have a short name there,
which corresponds to
the name up here that's
displayed on the home screen.
And then we have some
values for icons.
This gives you the ability to
add icons for different screen.
So in this example,
you could just
see the one that's
48 by 48 pixels.
But you can add icons that
work on different viewport
sizes, so different devices
like tablets or whatever.
And then this is
kind of a simple one.
You can add a
background color value.
Now what this does is gives
you a splash screen effect.
So when the app is
starting up, you
see that color displayed
onscreen with the icon
and the name displayed as well.
Now the purpose of
this is a simple thing.
But it gives the user
that instant effect
and that engagement they
get, that sense of trust,
because they get that
instant startup when they tap
on the icon on the home screen.
So just a simple way to make a
big improvement and keep the,
in some ways, the branding
of your app consistent.
Now I mentioned before the
problem with Add to Home Screen
from the menu, the
problem of where to start.
Well in the web app manifest,
you can specify a start URL.
So what we're saying
here is simply
that the start URL
is the index page.
A little thing you can
do with that, by the way,
is that you could add a
hash, a fragment, that
would specify that
for analytics,
that the user started
at an address, which
came from tapping on the
icon on the home screen.
So you could add
something like--
I don't know-- hash UMA
source = homescreen,
something like that,
just a simple way
to check how many of
your users are actually
getting to your app
via the home screen.
The other thing you'll see
here is display standalone.
What that means is that
the web app will have
an appearance very like an app.
If you have display browser,
for example, the app
will have much more of the
browser UI and UX components.
So they'll have the
ability to navigate
as if they were on a web page.
The last one here, kind
of straightforward,
is the orientation that
the app will start at.
If you think about, for example,
you built a keyboard app,
you would always want that
to start up in landscape.
And it would be
confusing to the user
if it didn't start up like that.
So in this case, it's portrait.
But for that keyboard app,
you'd make that landscape.
And that would make much
more sense to the user
than if it tried to start up
the keyboard in portrait made.
The theme color
defines how the app
is displayed in things like
the App Launcher by the system.
And in this case, it's
black to suit the branding,
in this case of the
Washington Post.
Again, another simple
way to keep that app-like
experience without
much effort at all.
That's just really easy.
So this is all good stuff.
It gives the user a more
consistent experience,
allows you to add that
branding and instant startup.
But we still had this
problem where users had
to install by going to a menu.
And that just wasn't happening.
So what the browser
vendors realized was
it would be better if
there was an automated
prompt for the user to install,
if the browser understood
that the user was
engaged with your app.
Now there are some conditions
for this, of course.
It doesn't just
happen immediately.
Firstly, like I said, when
you have an icon on the home
screen, it's like a contract
that the app will work offline.
So the first condition to
get a prompt from the browser
to install the screen is your
app must use Service Worker.
That's crucial, because
there is no other way
that you could be
providing a good offline
experience unless there was
Service Worker implemented.
Secondly the app has
to have a manifest.
So you get this
consistent experience,
like I was describing before.
And the third part of this
depends on the browser,
depends on different
rules, heuristics.
But essentially the idea is
that the user must show signs
of engagement with your app.
So that they've
been, for example,
using the app several times
over a certain amount of time.
So when those three
conditions are met,
the browser will prompt
the user to install
your app to home screen.
By the way, I won't go
into the details here.
But you can catch
the prompt event
and then defer that to
another time or, for example,
do something like add a
button to your site to install
this app to home screen.
So you have some
control at that point
over how the user is prompted
to install to home screen.
Now you might think, well,
why don't we just give
all this control to developers?
Like I say, the crucial part of
this is it must not be spammy.
It must feel like a
high quality experience.
It must be something
that a user trusts.
In other words, like I say,
an app must work offline.
You must get this
consistent experience
when the user taps on
the home screen icon.
And of course, if we
allowed developers
to pop the prompt to
install button immediately
that the user got to a website,
that's really frustrating.
You know those websites
you go to and as
soon as you go to
the website, you
get something popping up
saying install our app
or buy this or do something.
Users need to show
signs of engagement
before it's a good time
to prompt them to install.
So that's a great way to start
engaging your users, just
simply by having that
presence on the home screen
and also having a really good
install and startup experience.
Now I want to talk
a bit more about how
you can build on
engagement with users
and reengage with
users using something
called push notifications.
We've had some kind of push
notifications for many years,
various kinds of hacks or using
techniques with long polling
or whatever to be able
to push content to users.
But the nice thing is we
now have a standardized API
for doing push.
And the best part of this
is that the browser does not
need to be open for a push
message to be received.
In other words, you can send
a push message to a user
if they don't even
have the browser open.
As you can see here,
they will still
get a notification saying
that they have a push message.
This is hugely powerful.
And this is a fantastic
feature for engagement
that's been missing
from the web until now.
This is great for
you, the developer.
It makes life easier.
And we hope this is
good for users as well.
But actually it's good
for business as well.
I think Dion showed
this example before.
If you haven't seen this,
big e-commerce company
Jumia had a real problem with
abandoned shopping carts, where
users got partway
through a transaction
then gave up, and
then never came back
to complete transactions.
Now, Jumia tried various
methods to get around this.
They tried to get
users' email addresses.
And then if they abandoned
the shopping cart,
well they emailed
the users and say,
hey you abandoned
your shopping cart.
Do you want to
complete that purchase?
What they found
was they actually
got very poor results from that,
very low rate of conversions.
And of course, a
lot of users don't
like handing over
their email address
and getting email from
companies like that.
When they implemented push
notifications to do the same,
they got a much better
result. In general,
what we're finding
with push notifications
is that you get a really
high engagement level.
They're great for provoking
action in the user,
for getting the user
to do something.
In lots of different
scenarios, we're
finding the same effect,
not just for Jumia.
For them, it meant
a really big deal
in terms of their business.
But the core idea
here too is that it's
a way of engaging with users
individually without needing
them to give you, say, their
email address or some other
means to contact them.
They can get notifications
right in the browser
without any kind of asking
for extra information.
So let's have a look at that.
I'm going to get
onto the code later.
But I really first
wanted to take you
through some of the scenarios
of the user experience,
because this is a really
crucial part of making sure
that notifications work well.
Users are very
sensitive to this.
Users are very happy to
receive good notifications.
But of course,
users don't like it
when they get notifications that
feel like they're a nuisance.
They're being
spammed, and all that.
So I wanted to talk about some
of the principles of this.
And the first one is that
a notification absolutely
has to come at the right time.
I'll show you some
examples of that later.
But the message in
the notification
needs to matter to the
user right here, right now.
Secondly what you want is for
a notification to be specific.
I'll show examples of this.
But you want
specific information
in the notification, not
something vague or general,
but a specific action
that the user can take
or specific information that's
useful to the user right now.
Thirdly, of course, it has
to be relevant to the user.
This is part of the whole
business of it being personal.
I'd say as a general, rule avoid
sending just general messages
to all your users.
That's generally
not a good idea.
You need to send stuff that's
relevant to that person,
that user.
And I'll talk through
some ways to do that.
The core idea here is that when
you get a push notification,
you are being interrupted.
You know what it's like.
You're working or
you with friends.
And you get a
notification of some type.
It's an interruption.
So whatever you send
in a notification,
it has to be worth
it to the user
that they get that interruption.
That's a really simple idea.
My friend Pete here took
this fantastic photograph
in Antarctica, I believe.
He wants to do a developer
day there, as well.
Maybe one day in Antarctica
we'll have a developer day.
Anyway the point
of this image is
that these little cute penguins
here have been walking along,
going for a stroll.
And someone notified them and
said watch out, watch out.
There's this giant
leopard seal here.
And for the penguins, that
is relevant, and it's timely.
And it's personal for them.
It has meaning to them.
This is a kind of symbol of what
amounts to a good notification.
So let's try it out
with some real examples.
Remember these three ideas--
precise, timely, relevant.
Well this is a classic,
good, notification.
You get a notification
like this.
It tells you a particular
flight is delayed.
It even gives you the
new departure time.
You don't need to
do anything more.
This is all the
information you need.
This is actually a
pattern we've seen
with really good notifications
that you actually
can build a notification
that has everything right
there in the notification.
We often think of
notifications as a way
to get users to follow a
link and open a web page.
But you can also use
notifications to give
information right there.
So the user has
all the information
they need without having
to look anywhere else.
Now this is not so good.
So we've got a notification
that your credit
card has been compromised.
But you don't know
anything else.
It's too vague.
It's really hard to
know what's going on.
From that, you have
no idea what it means.
Now something like this
would be much better.
In this example, we've
got a similar message.
But it actually says what's
happened, what's gone wrong,
and why you need
to think about what
happened on the credit card.
And in this case, we've actually
got these two buttons here.
I'll show you how
to do this later.
But you can actually add
buttons to notifications.
So you can do stuff like
respond to a simple requests.
Confirm a reservation at
a restaurant or something
like that.
Google+, that's not so good.
Anyone use Google+?
I don't think so.
This is an OK message.
But there's nothing there.
There's no information.
Something like that
is much better.
It's personal, because it's
got the face of my friend.
And it's actually got a message
from them telling me what
I need to know, which is great.
Now imagine a company
like Google started
a self-driving taxi company.
You might call it Goober.
That would be good.
And this is another
good notification.
It's specific.
All the information
I need is right there
in the notification.
Do not do this.
If you implement
notifications, do not
use them to tell the user that
they've installed your app.
That is of no value to the user.
The notification has
to have something
that's of value to the user.
And that-- just don't do
it, nothing good about that.
Something like this
is kind of fine,
could be a bit better, but
yeah, a little more information,
perhaps, would work.
So I'd like to
just talk through,
before I get to the
code, actually give you
an overview of how
the process works
of subscribing users,
sending messages,
and then on the receiving side
how messages are displayed.
The nice thing about
the push API that it's
built on Service Worker.
Now as you've seen,
Service Workers
can be used to intercept
outgoing requests, so
to intercept a fetch request.
And this example, we're
getting a request there.
And then looking in the cache,
seeing if we've got something,
and if not, we go out to
the network and get it.
Now the cool thing
about Service Worker
is that it can also
handle incoming events.
So events from the operating
system or the network,
something like push.
So in this example, we
get a push event that's
handled by the Service Worker.
It you can say that it's just
responding to a push event
there that comes
from a push service.
And then we get the data
about the push events
from the data that's in the body
and icon and so on the JSON.
I'll talk more about
that in a moment.
The good thing about that is
that we have this ability for,
like I say, the Service
Worker to be woken up
when it's been asleep.
So you don't need to
have a process running
to receive push messages.
I'll talk more about that.
So here's the process
for subscribing users.
Well of course, the first
thing you've got to do
is check if the
user is subscribed.
If they're not subscribed,
you ask them to subscribe.
And then they go through
a subscription process.
They get subscription
data that identifies them
from the browser.
I'll show you how that works.
You then send that subscription
data to your server
and store it on the
server, on your server
so you can then contact that
user later to send a message.
Now on the send
side, you generate
a message on your server.
It needs to be encrypted.
You send, then, to
the push service.
And the push service
associated with the browser
then sends that
message to the user.
And then on the browser side,
we handle the incoming message.
Like I say, from
the server, we're
then generating
the message which
is sent to the individual user.
And then on the endpoint,
as in the device,
the operating system will
send a message to the browser.
The browser will wake up.
The Service Worker will wake up.
And then as the
push event happens,
the Service Worker starts.
And then the Service Worker
can display a notification
like we saw before.
Now the great thing about
this is that, like I say,
the Service Worker
doesn't have to be awake
to handle the message.
The Service Worker is woken up
when a push message arrives.
So just to give you a picture
of the whole setup again,
so for each browser, the browser
has its own push service.
So when you want to send
a message to the user,
you send a request
to the push service
with information that
identifies the user.
Then the push service sends
the message to the user.
And the endpoint then wakes
up the Service Worker.
And a notification
can be displayed.
So this might sound
a little unwebby,
because this idea that
we have a different push
service for each browser.
What's nice is
that this has been
standardized with something
called the Web Push Protocol.
What this means is
that no matter what
push service the
browser uses, you
write the same code, the
same JavaScript on the client
side, the same code
on the server side,
to be able to send
and handle messages.
This is really nice, because
I don't know if people--
has anyone in the past
used push notifications?
Has anyone built push
notifications in their apps?
A few people.
People may have
noticed before, you
had to set up
individual IDs and so
on to use push notifications.
Well the nice thing now is
that push notifications work
the same way in every browser.
And what that means
is as you may know,
push is not
supported by iOS yet,
like Safari running on iOS.
But when it is, your
code will work on iOS
exactly as it will now
on browsers running
on Android, which is great.
So we also need to
authenticate the transactions,
the communication between
the user and your server
and between your
server and the user.
You need to be able to
trust that a request
for a subscription
comes from the user
that you think it does.
And the other way
around, the user
must be able to trust
that a message received
is actually from the site
that they think they're
getting the message from.
Now the protocol we have
for this is called VAPID.
I won't go into the
details, particularly.
But the core idea here
is that the communication
between the user and your
web service is authenticated.
And the communication
between your web server
via the Push service to
the user is authenticated.
So the user can trust you.
And you can trust the user.
This is absolutely crucial.
You can do a lot of this work to
set up push messaging yourself.
What I would say
is that have a look
at our libraries for web push.
These are maintained
by the Chrome team.
They're really well-written.
And even if you're rolling your
own push messaging service.
I would recommend that
you use these libraries.
It's just like, for example,
a server using nodes.
It's a really, really
straightforward way
to generate and send messages
just using the library.
And we have code labs
for that as well.
So you can try that out.
So I do want to run through
the actual code for this,
beginning by talking about
subscribing and unsubscribing.
So the first thing
you need to do,
this is a progressive web app.
So we need to actually
check that Service Worker is
implemented, by seeing if we
can see that in Navigator.
And then once the Service Worker
is registered successfully,
we can then get at
the push manager API.
Now the push manager
API is what we use
to manage subscription data.
And in this example, we're
getting a subscription.
So that subscription
object, like this bit,
is what has the information
about the identity of the end
user.
That's the data that enables
you, your web server,
to be able to send a
message to the right user.
And I'll show you how we
go on with that later.
So if we need to
subscribe the user,
if they hadn't
subscribed already,
it's kind of a similar process.
We get the Service
Worker registration.
And then we subscribe the user.
Now you'll see a
couple of options here.
The first one here,
userVisibleOnly:true,
this is really crucial.
If you're receiving push
messages in your application,
you must show a notification.
This is not an API.
This is not a way to push data.
This is specifically an
API for sending messages
to be displayed
in notifications.
If you don't show
a notification when
you receive a push
message, pop a notification
from your Service
Worker, the system,
the browser will pop up
a dialog saying that it
received a notification.
The idea of this is
that otherwise, it
would be possible
for a malicious site
to just continually
send thousands
of messages to the end user.
And that's just a
simple way to stop that.
The application server key
has encryption data for,
like I say, making sure that the
communication is authenticated
all the way from the
user to your web server
and by the push service
back to the user.
And in this example, it
shows that then once we've
got the subscription object,
what we're doing in this case
is calling a function
that then would actually
send the subscription
data to your server.
And in other words, that's the
identifying data for the user
that you would send to your
server that enables you then
to send a message to that
particular user, what's
called the endpoint data.
And then obviously
in all of this,
we just have console logs here.
But make sure if you're
implementing push notifications
that you work well
with UI and UX
to ensure that the
user understands
when they subscribed and when
that happened successfully.
So let's look at that
in a little more detail.
Like I said, this
subscription object
is what identifies the user.
This is what you
save on your server,
so that when you make a
request to the push service
to send the user
a message that you
have some way of
identifying which user
it is you're talking about.
So that's that bit
at the top there.
This represents
the push service.
And this bit here is identifier
for the individual user.
And then we've got
the keys to ensure
that that process is secure.
Little diversion here
about user experience.
It's really important that,
like Add to Home Screen,
that you choose the right moment
to prompt a user if they would
like to receive push messages.
Now what we have
seen in some apps
is that as soon as you go to
the website, you get a message.
A dialog popped up.
Would you like to
subscribe to push messages?
In general, that
is not a good time.
You need to wait until the user
is showing signs of engagement
before you actually
prompt them if they would
like to receive push messaging.
Alternatively you
can just let them
do that you know interactively.
And I'll show an
example of that.
If you do pop up a prompt
to receive push messages,
make sure it's really
clear what's going on.
Make sure that the
user understands
what they're being asked
and what the process is.
A really nice
example of people who
are doing a really
good job of prompting
for push notifications
is the Weather Channel.
What they have is
very clear UI, UX
for subscribing to
push notifications.
And what's nice is that
it's clear for the user
that what's happening,
in the first place,
but also that they
then have the ability
to choose different
types of notifications,
so for different
sections of the site.
This is really important.
If you're not sure
what users might
want from your site in
terms of notifications,
then think about sending
different notifications
for different subjects.
So in this example,
the Weather Channel
gives the user the option to
subscribe to breaking news,
whatever that means.
Or they can just
subscribe to alerts that
are issued by the government.
So give the user options.
If you think you have more
than one kind of push message,
then give the user
options to choose.
Unsubscribing--
obviously, you have
to give users a nice
interface for unsubscribing.
Some users may
unsubscribe, resubscribe.
Make sure that process
of unsubscribing
is really seamless.
And it works well.
Here's the code for that.
Again we're getting the Service
Worker registration object.
And then once we get
the subscription object,
it's as simple as calling
the unsubscribe method.
And that means the user is
then unsubscribed to push
messages for that domain.
Now, like I said, we have
the Web Push Protocol,
which is really nice, because
it standardizes the process
of sending messages.
The core part of this is that
messages must be encrypted.
We need the whole
communication flow
to be encrypted from
start to finish.
So when you send a message
from your web server
to the push service, that
message must be encrypted.
Let's actually have a look
at the payload for that.
Remember, that was the
subscription object
identifies the user.
This is given to
us by the browser.
So at the start here, we have
the URL for the push service.
And the last part of
this is the identifier
for the individual user.
So when you want to send
a message to a user,
it's as simple as making
a put request to the push
service, which looks like that.
Let's break this down a bit.
The first part is
the actual domain
of the origin of
the push service.
And then the path,
which includes
what we call the endpoint.
So this, again, is the bit
that identifies the user.
Did anyone see this
last-- this was crazy--
I think last year?
There was a video
of a shark eating
through an internet cable.
Unbelievable, I
think in Vietnam.
It's incredible, just
destroying an internet cable.
Anyway the point of this is that
you cannot rely on your user
being online.
So what we have in the
payload or the headers,
rather, for the request to
the service is a Time to Live,
TTL, Time to Live.
What this one specifies
is for the push service
to keep trying for 120 seconds
to send a message to the end
user.
Now if you think about it, there
are some messages which have
to be received immediately .
If they're not received
within, say, one minute then
they are irrelevant.
There are other
messages that might
be valid to send
for several hours.
So you know that TTL value
is really handy for sending
different types of messages.
Like I say, it is
the number of seconds
that the push service
will keep trying to send
a message to the end user.
And then we've got some
other necessary headers there
for content type and encoding
and encryption values
and the authorization value.
Like I say, we have
this exchange of keys
so that we can be
sure that the user is
who we think they are, and
for the users' point of view
that they're receiving the
message, the actual message
that you sent and from the
site that they think they're
getting that message from.
And then we have an
authorization header
there as well.
And this last bit is
meant to represent
the actual encrypted payload.
The cool thing is now,
just to repeat that,
that you can send a
payload in a notification.
At the very start
of this, it wasn't
actually possible to
send a payload all
you could do was notify
the end user that there
was a notification.
But just to be clear, it's now
possible to send a payload.
And I'll talk a bit
more about that now.
Like I say, check out
the Web Push libraries,
because this is
much the easiest way
to send push messaging
from your server.
We'll have some URLs at the end,
too, that we'll share with you.
So on the incoming side, this
is pretty straightforward.
In the Service Worker, you're
listening out for a message.
Like I say the browser doesn't
even have to be opening.
The system will wake up
the browser, will wake up
the Service Worker.
And the Service Worker
will get a push event.
Then from the push event,
just look at the data.
Get the JSON from that.
And in this case, showering
a simple notification
with a title, some body
text, the icon data.
And then this last
part, the tag value,
now what this does is allows you
to send multiple notifications
on the same subject.
What that means is that
the browser will not
pop up different notifications.
It won't keep popping
up new notifications.
It will understand that
you're sending, maybe,
a different message but
using the same notification.
So it's just a way, in a sense,
of grouping notifications
to avoid sending push messages
that result in more and more
and more notification dialogs.
Here's an example of a pattern
we're seeing a lot now.
Like I say, one of the nice
things about push notifications
is that you can actually get the
whole experience for the user
in the notification.
No need to go to a web page.
No need to--
I don't know-- go
anywhere, do anything.
They can actually complete
their task right there
in the notification.
So in this example, they're
just confirming a restaurant
booking, really simple.
All the information is there.
It's precise.
It's relevant.
It's timely.
And all the action happens
right there in the notification,
a really nice pattern
we're seeing in lots
and lots of different contexts.
So for that example
to get those buttons,
you have this bit here, which
is the action stuff here.
So to have a button
displayed in a notification,
you give the action name.
And you give it a title,
what's actually displayed,
and then an icon, the image
that's displayed next to it.
And then I'll show
you how that works.
So once the user actually
clicks on the notification,
you'll get a notification click
event that you can handle.
And then you listen
out for the event,
and then check the
name of the action--
or the action, rather.
In this case, we're
looking for one called like
and then acting accordingly.
So we can make a
fetch request that
shows that that user
clicked on a like button.
Or we could do some
other stuff too.
We could open a window
or lots of other actions.
So I think these notifications
are really, really powerful.
The core idea is
that we're seeing
users are very active in
response to notifications.
They are a great way of
keeping this connection,
building this engagement
with users, without--
if you get it right--
without being intrusive.
There are lots of great
things we're seeing.
We're really
interested to see what
you do with push notifications,
really interesting stuff
that people are doing with that,
maybe not what we've expected.
We have a lot of
information online.
Please take a look
at this stuff.
There's a stack of stuff
on our web fundamentals
site about push notifications,
a lot of information there.
And we're regularly
writing updates as well,
as changes come in and
new features are built
and we see more implementations.
Like I say, really
looking forward
to what you make of
push notifications.
All I can say, we would
love to hear from you.
So thank you very much.
And yeah, if you're doing
something great with push
notifications, please email me.
If you have questions,
come and talk to us.
We'd love to find out more about
what people are doing with push
notifications and if you're
coming up against problems as
well.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING MANDARIN]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
In my opinion, the
[? people ?] want
to improve the user experience
at mobile available,
at web in the Chrome.
But I want to know the
PWA and hybrid apps,
can you compare
between two things?
And when the first question,
and the second question
is with user, just phones,
the push notification,
can I call the Android
[? relay ?] table notification?
Or can I call Android telephone?
Maybe this [? relay ?]
table actually can I do.
That's two questions.
SAM DUTTON: So the first
question I wasn't sure about.
The second question, you
could, I guess, fire an intent,
call an intent URL.
Would that work?
I'm not sure that would.
I don't think that will.
So I'm not sure
that there's a way
to make a-- like you're
asking to make a telephone
call in response
to a notification?
AUDIENCE: Pardon?
SAM DUTTON: For the user
would make a telephone call
in response to a notification.
AUDIENCE: When people want
to respond to the push
notification, maybe the
people want to call,
want to [INAUDIBLE]
Android, Android [? relay ?]
table notification.
Will Android [? relay ?]
table telephone message.
And maybe the push notification
can call Android [? relay ?]
table application.
SAM DUTTON: I don't
think there's any way
to access the Android telephone,
so to speak, from a push
notification.
No.
AUDIENCE: Just the
only push notification,
not cannot call
[? relay ?] table
SAM DUTTON: No I
don't think there's
any way that you could access
the telephone functionality so
to speak.
Maybe come and chat
to me afterwards.
I'll see if I can
give more information.
What was the first
question though?
It was the difference between--
AUDIENCE: The first
question, I want
to know can you compare
PWA and hybrid apps?
This two protection--
SAM DUTTON: So PWA
and hybrid apps?
SAM DUTTON: Well there
may be contexts where
a hybrid app works really well.
It depends.
It depends on your need.
If you need an app that
must appear in an app store,
then you might want
to build a hybrid app.
Otherwise there are lots
of good reasons for,
I would say, for using
progressive web apps.
The biggest reason
from my perspective
is that you reduce the barrier
to users actually getting
at your app.
I think Dion's
example was fantastic,
where he could send his
father a link to a page.
And he's not asking
his father to install
an app or anything like that.
So I think it depends on your
requirements as a developer.
I think my advice would be to
try using a progressive web
app.
And then if you feel a need to
have an app in an app store,
then maybe consider hybrid apps.
I don't think it's clear cut.
It's not never use hybrid apps.
I don't think there are specific
scenarios where necessarily
one is better than the other.
AUDIENCE: I have
a little question
about the manifest
is setting, in fact,
my [? paging ?] strategy.
So if I installed my
website on the desktop.
And I update my
resources or assets
where the icon
refresh are renewed.
SAM DUTTON: OK, no.
At the moment, no.
But I believe there's
some work to fix that.
You mean if you
update the icon, you
want the home screen
icon to be updated.
At the moment, no.
But we want to see
that in future.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you.
SAM DUTTON: That's a really good
point, because it's crucial--
if your brand changes and so on.
AUDIENCE: Will Android Web View
plan to support push service?
SAM DUTTON: Sorry,
say that again.
AUDIENCE: Will Android Web View
plan to support push service?
SAM DUTTON: So how
does, not good.
Yeah, Pete's making the point
that if you were working
with a the hybrid app, you
would probably be implementing
push natively anyway.
SPEAKER 2: At that point,
you've got a native app.
So why not just use the
typical native stuff?
And that is the smarter,
more efficient way.
If you already
have a native app,
it's no need to put push
notifications in a web view.
AUDIENCE:
[? Third party ?] browser,
in [INAUDIBLE] and push
service or other app?
SPEAKER 2: That's--
SAM DUTTON: Like for other apps?
SPEAKER 2: So you're
saying for somebody
who's building a browser
that just wraps a web view,
so you've got your own, your
browser vendor without actually
building a browser.
Is that right?
SAM DUTTON: There's no
reason why you can't, why--
say you had a browser that
was within a hybrid app.
There's no reason why
the hybrid app can't
receive push notifications
and then notify the browser as
if the browser had been outside
of a hybrid app, so to speak.
SPEAKER 2: I think
the key piece there--
and I don't have
the answer to this--
is I don't know if Service
Workers work in web view.
And my guess is that they don't.
But I'm not positive on that.
So that would be the
whole gating factor.
AUDIENCE: OK thank you.
SPEAKER 1: One last question?
AUDIENCE: Hello, sir, a
very wonderful speech.
My question is the web push
notifications based on the GCN?
SAM DUTTON: OK, yeah, so
on Chrome on Android, yes.
But the crucial thing about
the push API and the Web Push
Protocol is that
you can implement
with different browsers,
can implement web push
notifications with a
different push service.
AUDIENCE: And do you think
it will work well in China
based on the GCM?
SAM DUTTON: Well it
depends on the browser.
It depends on, say, like if--
I mean I know actually UC use
a different system for push
notifications.
But if UC or QQ
or other browsers
want to implement
push notifications,
they can certainly do that
using their own Push service.
It's up to the browser vendor
to choose a push service
that they interact with.
The nice thing about
the standardization
is that as a developer, you
don't need to change your code.
The point of that is that
you would write the same code
on the client, same JavaScript,
same code on the server side.
And it would just work,
given the standardization
of the APIs.
So it's up to the
browser vendors
to choose what push
service they use.
But the actual underlying
APIs will just work.
AUDIENCE: One last
question, would you
explain a little bit of GCM?
I really wonder how does
this work, the theory?
SAM DUTTON: So well,
the core idea is that--
I actually don't know the
real detail of how it works.
But the core concept
is that there
is the minimal possible
traffic between the push
service and the endpoint.
Some things I do know
is that some messages
can be bundled together so
that you know that the end user
device isn't constantly being
woken up and using radio.
So services like GCM
running with Android
use a lot of clever
algorithms to make sure
that there's the minimal
traffic between the two sockets,
so to speak, between the service
and the end user, the operating
system on the device.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SAM DUTTON: It's nothing--
what we've had in the
past is stuff which,
like long polling,
which essentially you're
constantly making requests
and refreshing those.
The nice thing
about push messaging
like this, standardized, is
that it uses the underlying
operating system features to
minimize the battery, CPU,
memory usage.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Thanks, Sam.
SAM DUTTON: Thank you.